that's two hours from Vegas but the big
[Music]
we stayed like an hour away you could
pay more and stay like add the Grand
Canyon why would it do that why do you
do that why would you do that there's no
foot up there there's no fool of day
don't mean that that's your best bet
you're not [ __ ] food there's no food
in this whole town but there's a me
right next to the Grand Canyon you form
down with the [ __ ] Momo's he just
they have beaten beat it will do the
same I'm surprised there's nothing up
there
it's but you got the Grand Canyon
tonight who could say they got their
dicks up from the Grand Canyon you don't
sign up to let it that's what's up there
I got my fix I'm through the Grand
Canyon
you ever think of that whatever Laughlin
much we'll stop and help just gonna help
nobody goes to happen
[Music]
who the [ __ ] goes to Laughlin Nevada
would somebody please tell me you're
plenty people there yeah well you people
man
okay unbelievers which Monday night
[ __ ] it's gonna be a smoky night
here tonight
we got big dreams and big ambitions you
don't say
[Music]
that's the way it's gonna be like
Grandpa's basement
we [ __ ] around tonight
where you go we gotta get all the bad
spirits out of the room
you bad [ __ ] uncle Joey here
it's been a while we're back in the
Voodoo Lounge if you're under 18 get the
[ __ ] outta here you little [ __ ]
douchebag I don't want you in my life I
don't watch anywhere around me your
little young [ __ ] shoutouts to all you
bad [ __ ] Monday night I don't
know North Carolina's wouldn't or lose
them they will lose them by 2:00 when I
left the house what are you gonna do who
gives a [ __ ] if you didn't bet shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] if you got your
Jersey on I've been a Tarheel fan it's
just the beginning but they weren't
looking too good tonight then when I'm
making free throws the other day who
gives a [ __ ] it's Monday night free
church we got off we got the bag of
goods my manly saddle be representing
tonight as usual he's going deep in the
murky water let this over the 16th April
in time for 4/20 and that's a complete
different story we're gonna have [ __ ]
we're gonna eat edibles and get
electroshock on 4/20 that's how we're
doing
I ain't 1725 last night we'll see what's
a good scars too
[Music]
they look like they've been dipped in
sabzi
oh [ __ ] he's a 10 star general tonight
ba ba ba ba keeping it alive for the
churches you what are you [ __ ] nuts
or what we're going deep to look at the
Stars we're gonna [ __ ] tape all of
the men when Gerardo opened up Capone
safe there was nothing in there we get
the bags hermetically sealed you
understand me I have [ __ ] up already
it's Monday we got Steve Simone on he
brought up with some [ __ ] pizza he
made delicious we got two different
blends tonight we got the superglue are
you [ __ ] kidding me or what look at
this look at my eyes look at that I
can't even see anymore I smoke somebody
bonded to this this is this [ __ ] that's
gonna put you over the top and then we
got this the [ __ ] colossal og it's
like a [ __ ] gorillas foot that's what
it smells like understand me are you
ready for bonding leading at the party
started
let's do a pong a Rooney here I don't
want you to say Joey didn't give me a
[ __ ] bonnet you're a [ __ ]
what's happening Nyack New York I loved
you last week you [ __ ] solid
when the guy got hit in the head with
the bottle I knew I was at the right
[ __ ] location you understand me who
needs these okey-doke [ __ ] clubs with
people want to serve your chicken
parmesan I don't want no chicken
parmesan I want somebody to get hit in
the head in the [ __ ] men's bathroom
that's when you know you went to a
comedy show you understand me
will you're ready for the super Louie
she's two so far yeah he's got two on
his hands hidden I think it does to you
people at night he hides
like the magician how dare you I know
how dare you gonna have to do cuz I
don't believe the [ __ ] camera I know
you Paula do something over there
you forget I know you're an editor way
back I know you do the tricks is [ __ ] he
does tricks with the [ __ ] live
streaming see I'm an old man I don't
know nothin about those youngster things
he's all young he's not internet sassy
guys are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] nuts that's how we're doing it
here you people think I'm [ __ ] around
Hannah we're smoking this Internet we've
we've got debt on two legs that's what
they call this weed this super glue this
is the [ __ ] that killed Kennedy Nixon
[ __ ] Mickey Rourke this is this [ __ ]
Mickey rug did when he cut up his
[ __ ] face look at his central nervous
system he's sweating you want to keep
smoking that my mother on over the
border from some [ __ ] up neighborhood
or you want to come run with uncle Joey
make up your [ __ ] mind [ __ ]
it's the church always happen now Monday
April [ __ ] 3rd except you are there
you understand me
let's do this [ __ ] do this [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] it's that type of
night Steve Simone's here he brought
pizzas were on and on [ __ ] you
better get excited I don't give a [ __ ]
spring is here right March 21st spring
is sprung anyway
[Music]
we go oh [ __ ]
Saturday night bring it on home [ __ ]
suck this what with Jimmy Holloway jr.
running things in Secaucus hit him up on
Twitter Facebook you're good to go
police say you recover do you wait for
another one what happened
Jesus Christ
I give you a fresh bowl every time I got
nothing but mad respect for you I would
never give you out listen I'll do a lot
of things you understand now kidnap your
grandmother for a small envelope but
I'll never give you [ __ ] bad wheat
listen it's not my [ __ ] realm you
understand me I think you're [ __ ] to the
hoop every night Saturday night hi what
are you [ __ ] method a method to do
hall and company [ __ ] oh my god
drink a little water I'm getting [ __ ]
flustered you want a soda the party
started how good is that [ __ ] reason
that you should've got the hotel on the
top of [ __ ] Mount Sinai wherever you
went and ran up and down 15 times you
couldn't get high anyway well here would
win everything all right in your world I
hope it is if you're feeling gloomy or
depressed or you had a bad day you know
what suck it up [ __ ] everybody has bad
days and good days they don't last
forever you understand me [ __ ] it get it
out of your mind get that bong head out
at the pipe whatever you need to help
you get to the next level tomorrow
morning if you're doing heroin you can't
be doing heroin it's not that type of
party people are dying every [ __ ] day
there's no cocaine allowed here
there's no [ __ ] pills allowed here
this is a strait reef or [ __ ] Club
you know I'm saying I mean listen if you
got a valium and you drink a little
whiskey I got a Bobby a little valium
never killed nobody go to sleep you
understand me happy a [ __ ] hypocrite
if I didn't but all that of this shit's
gonna [ __ ] kill you
the bong replaced did you see the
[ __ ] news this week states that have
medical marijuana opiate and have less
visitations to the [ __ ] Hospital do
the opiate [ __ ] overdoses I didn't
make that up I'm not telling you to
smoke weed I'm not one of those guys
I'll have a poster high times I don't
vote I don't give a [ __ ] what you do in
this family I'm just telling you though
you want to stay on top of your game do
a little food salutes and get your [ __ ]
together
Lee's over here choking a dead no one
can train for this basic training
training training is if you would have
done three bong hits over the weekend up
in the high altitude right or wrong you
want to be a player you want to be a
king all these [ __ ] talking
about the earth is flat I don't get I
don't care if it's flat a triangle was
still walking around slinging dick with
rollerskates they'll do nothing I was a
good movie last night above the law
Steven Seagal 1987 his first [ __ ]
movie cooking only then watch the little
[ __ ] Steven Seagal and his first [ __ ]
that movie I believe you ever see that
movie dog I saw that no I wouldn't watch
it at first I used to say [ __ ] Steve
Sagat
or when I kidnapped a fella I went
hiding for two days I had to kill time
and I watch two movies that I'm very
happy I'm very happy that kidnap can't
go sometimes good good things came out
of it but the what the two things was I
got to watch Lethal Weapon I wouldn't
watch that and I got to watch whatever
the [ __ ] that is looking poorly how many
doubts
four left this what I got to deal with
every man I hate 17:25 he can't it would
take him the [ __ ] listen to me
the periscope would take three hours if
this guy ate among camp it's already
taken twenty minutes I would add twenty
of them by now already I'm making a
comeback with two cheese let's go let's
get this started hit above the law you
ever see this movie
no why would you watch this movie you
want to watch orange is the new purple
I'm saying is I got to deal with on a
Monday afternoon what else what else you
bad [ __ ] it's you
let's do another bottle everybody wanna
do a lot of Bongo let's do another
bucket city of wasting you for a crime
you want to chitchat you call young
saying we're here chitchat with some fat
[ __ ] felon Paris go get your life
together young Saint then you wonder why
you're still mopping floors [ __ ]
you owe me a hand with some [ __ ] fat
dude for the white tea set up he bought
at the fat man stuff anyway
[Music]
hey always nice to have you at the
church what's happened now you know that
guys always [ __ ] nice dad alright I
feel [ __ ] haunted you're gonna put
above the law
first fight scene oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I can't see without my glasses the suit
Rhea
[Music]
now scroll it down the one at the [ __ ]
this is cool - right there ginkgo econ
one under that click this that's bad for
the bump I don't know if it all and then
the next one to fight at the Indian
store right there click the fight at the
Indian store for watching above the law
1987 Steven Seagal at the [ __ ] Indian
store look at this right now they shoot
him in the car right he fades for guys
with machine guns
alright they don't know where the [ __ ]
he is right it's a great scene they
double shoot look at Bobby Lee's uncle
yeah look at Tom Segura before the head
transplant freeze [ __ ]
once this Stephen walks them into the
[ __ ] 7-eleven one
look at Tom Segura three times ago my
time is done
watch this he takes him into the [ __ ]
hindu store now in a Polish neighborhood
[ __ ] tremendous lead you never saw
this man no why would you look at
[ __ ] look look at Ibiza fake into the
booth he's a fake
he's a fake missing out puts on these
[ __ ] this guy check this [ __ ]
up get the [ __ ] down you want to get
down [ __ ] what here we go watch
this Barney hey guys fire three of them
look at the four Hindu he knows look at
this boom oh [ __ ]
look at nYSCI yeah the [ __ ]
refrigerator BAM people moving my pen
what the [ __ ] he talking about there
you go he breaks his fingers there you
go punch to the head
watch this here this beautiful white
Chinese tremendous move in 1987 and look
at the mother's last guy out the [ __ ]
window you get me or what this is what
I'm talking about
1987 you can laugh all the [ __ ] you
wanted Steven Seagal now he's a fat [ __ ]
like me but an 87 [ __ ] tremendous put on
the scene before this with the [ __ ]
at the at the after the the beginning
watched it once don't believe people
think you're dealing with here you want
good movies I gave you a jihad and the
big brown review look at the beginning
click Italy watch this this is the
opening [ __ ] scene of this movie
watch this it's the opening scene is
[ __ ] there he is
oh [ __ ] if you haven't seen above the
Lord dog you better get your life
together look at him oh [ __ ] Aikido and
[ __ ] Cambria way before yeah
this is Aikido old-school jack Sharon
Stone when she was still chubby before
she showed up [ __ ] this is Sharon Stone
before she showed a [ __ ] in 1991 she
was still chubby on the thighs she
probably had curly hair and look who is
the [ __ ] writer on this movie one of
the writers Steven Pressfield the art of
war watch this move look at that move
right there that Steve Simone 1982 with
his brother in the bedroom at night I'm
getting the last slice [ __ ] you no I'm
not watch watch him here what Doug I'm
going to show you some wild [ __ ] right
here look at the room
this is when bp's with bb's watch this
and front in front of the grandma
[Music]
always oh my [ __ ] god
Steven Seagal 87 the church' was
happening now coming at you ten minutes
all right you where is it look he's
still eating [ __ ] stars people say
that dealing if this was any other time
in my life I could shoot him and get
away with mine I put him enough trunk
like Billy Blanks he's I'm saying like
take him to steve Simone's he'd make up
beats and then we go put him in the yard
but I'm a different type of person now I
like Jewish people I like everybody
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz let me
tell you something I must have done 18
buckets and I have you don't think I'm
seeing the devil you're absolutely wrong
I'm like Irish right now look at my nose
it's on fire and that's not from
sniffing [ __ ] that's from just weed
my blood vessels of my nose have said
kaput I got cottonmouth I don't know
what I'm talking about but I'll see you
guys in 10 minutes stay black uncle Joey
loves you thank you for joining the free
church periscope you bad mother finally
I mean it stars you got left Lea and
your little grubby fingers trying to put
them away there's a lie to you tie a
2048 1,800